all right so wait there's this netflix
documentary called the tinder swindler
oh yes we were talking about this
earlier yeah that's my dude okay
i don't know anything about it okay no
basically this guy went on tinder and
defrauded women that he met he's out
there in europe thousands
yeah so here's what's interesting just
the context so it's basically this uh
netflix dr marital right now of course
none of us have seen it but we're going
to talk about it and basically what he
did is he's a dude in europe and he was
basically dating these girls and getting
like borrowing money from these girls to
just ball out for other girls yeah so we
had like like a like a bernie madoff
little situation going where he's just
taken from this girl and then taking
private jets with that girl and just
keep keep running what i think is so
funny about it is uh uh when there's a
story of a man who takes advantage of
women and uses them for their money
right
it gets a documentary right like that is
how shocking this is
that netflix is like we need to print
this story and let everybody know who
this is yeah when you could make the
argument that this is a
common practice
out there in the world for uh some
ladies to gold dig on rich dudes no he's
just having this city girl moment i'm
not mad at him
it's just like
it's just
that's the dude no no no no no no i'm
gonna say this so i i i this is an old
story this happened like 2015 so i was
on youtube watching like videos about
this
and and the funny thing that had me
rolling was these women who were like i
was convinced he was a rich man so i
just i gave him fifty thousand dollars
he took me on a yacht they took me on a
plane so i tried the wording of that
[ __ ] yeah i was convinced he was a rich
man right and he's like he hit me up one
day and he's like listen i'm having
issues with my credit card if you can
just front me the money i'll be down to
pick you up in my jet next week but i
just need to pause and the girl's like i
had no reason not to believe him he was
so charming and elegant he the facade he
put on the clothes he wears the hotel
the limousines he used the scam was
genius but it's just something funny
about these girls thinking they found
themselves a big fish and they're like
i'm settled for life and then carpet
came out underneath them the the look on
their face when they found out
crazy beautiful wow beautiful because
you never hear about it so it's just
kind of like it's a nice change of pace
you feel me yeah yeah i enjoyed it it's
a change
it's just crazy that he did to me what i
wanted to do to him
shut up
shut her mouth
but yeah this guy's a master swindler he
did stuff in israel went to jail for it
and then after he got out went to europe
started defrauding all these women his
commitment to the game is what i'm
impressed by i mean because you have to
understand he's rolling with high stakes
and if you're pulling it off in israel
he was doing and got caught he's like
that's the nba and then he's going to
finland
that's funny shout out to him what's the
guy's name do we know his minion
oh that's right
simon leviev was like the main name that
they use in the documentary but his name
shimone juliet yeah some last name i
can't pronounce some [ __ ] like that and
did you watch the documentary yeah last
night was it crazy or whatever i put it
at 1.5 speed because it was so good that
i was like i need to know what happens
it's so good yeah did they show the
girls were they huh yeah there's three
girls that they showed they were hot
yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're also they were like mid 30s like
they were professionals like mid 30s so
that was like seven years ago so that
you know white women age like bread so
they don't look good now they
interviewed them yeah but what type of
bread they were hot yeah what type of
beer mcdonald's
yeah wonder bread
all right fair enough wonderful i think
age is good that just stays looking like
wonder bread forever does it yeah no i
wonder brad be getting [ __ ] rotten
bro no it just dries out it's all
processed you just used to wonder bread
[ __ ]
yeah those women were smoking like you
watched old videos of them they were hot
you had to go for women like who are
about to hit their peak and like peter
out because they had money in the bank
he couldn't go for 20 year olds so he's
picking young like professionals that
were established had good careers very
smart oh that's smart because you saw
the way those women dressed they were
dressing classy right kids they ask for
it is that what you're saying
they were asking for interest i'm like
not the metaverse what oh sorry dude i'm
sorry dude my bad all right let me just
imagine being in the metaverse and being
raped by a dude who sounds like [ __ ]
can you imagine staying there for the
other guys
just take off the [ __ ] oculus
right
i'm not in front i'm ready for like
virtual reality sex what do you mean
i mean i've tried virtual reality stuff
and i'm like i wouldn't mind because you
know they're already doing surgeries
where they some [ __ ] puts his
hand in the glove and he's in like
united states and there's somebody in
like india who needs a heart transplant
and the surgeon's doing it remotely
[ __ ] i ain't know that so imagine
there's just some girl in [ __ ]
ukraine and you're like you want a hand
job from her she puts her hand in a
glove you put your [ __ ] in the pocket
[ __ ] you feel me yeah all right man
y'all look at the promises no no let him
go let him go this is good i like when
you're getting passionate about your
things i'm just saying wouldn't that be
crazy like you could do long distance it
would change long distance forever yeah
you can't [ __ ] a girl but you can't
yeah but you give her bigger titties you
can like update that [ __ ] but here's the
thing how do you know that it's a girl
exactly and how do you not know this
just preach [ __ ] around with you in
the next room i would like i bet this
dude let me jerk his ass off this dumb
[ __ ]
hey
you just [ __ ] up and actually speak in
your voice
he's just
open your mouth
[Applause]
you